so you made all of your money back on
your first independent film a card
decision which is something we rarely
hear of people doing first off where did
you meet those investors where did you
obtain them and then what was the
process like okay well the investors
actually already knew me so being you
know you want to first of all approach
people that you know in in my situation
having you know being an established
professional I was in contact with other
professionals and it's interesting the
United States there's a lot of
non-traditional investors that are very
much interested in Hollywood you know
and you you really be surprised and it's
not here in California you can go
anywhere you can go to like Las Vegas
for instance or New York or anywhere in
the country and people are very much
enthralled with Hollywood and they like
to be involved whether it's you know
behind the scenes or not so you want to
go to people you know and you know you
have to have a background when you're
approaching individuals who are going to
invest in a project so it's like it's
like anything it's like being a I guess
it's like being a broker and you're
approaching someone is saying hey I got
this great portfolio of stocks and I
want you to invest in it because I I can
make you a return so a lot of a lot of
this goes plays on the credibility of
the individual who's selling the project
and I was selling the project
fundamentally and with these people I
was very credible I wasn't I was
extremely professional they knew exactly
what I was about and they they knew my
mo they knew that I'm not someone who's
going to be frivolous with funds but I
have a very specific vision for a
project and a plan on how to get them
their return on their investment so
that's that's the approach I took which
is probably a little bit different I
think then some of the people who are
locally trying to make films my I guess
what I would say is really use your own
network first try and try and exhaust
that before going to the traditional
sources like you know going
downtown and in finding a production
house or pitching your script at the AFM
what types of materials did you present
these investors with like let's say you
know you were a broker and you were
going to show them your quarterly
reports or something what did you show
them to to make them besides them
knowing you personally and you know
having an existing relationship well you
have to show them well first of all the
big thing is how much money do you
already have in the film so for me you
know I had invested twenty percent of
the film I'm already so I already had a
certain amount of absolutely as I said
before skin in the game that's huge
that's really important because a lot of
times you hear about people getting
money from investors and just being very
frivolous with it and I'm talking on all
levels I'm talking about directors
producers actors you know and so forth
there it's really easy to be frivolous
with other people's money and and that's
just not professional and it's not the
way to conduct yourself so they already
knew how much of investment I was making
any which is 20 percent and I'm looking
for the rest of the eighty percent so a
lot of this has to a lot of his thought
of this is dependent on how much faith
they have in you as a person who's going
to be able to deliver on a promise so a
lot of it does go back to personality
and and having a record of being an
upright individual so that's a big part
of it then the second part of it is
what's the strategy so what's the
audience that you're trying to target so
in my case concrete decision was made
for a foreign audience and what I did
was I did research on theatrical sales
in India where I wanted to release this
film and I gave them the numbers I said
look if we invest this much it's a safe
bet that we can get a return on our
investment if as long as we don't go
over this amount of money and if we can
get at the optical release in India
which we did it was a national release
we should be able to make the money back
as long as we're really smart on the on
the flip side of it making sure that the
the distributors are actually giving us
you know our fair share
you